This one is true, the mode can be used to describe any type of data, numerical
or categorical. You saw in the last quiz that male versus female is categorical
and the mode was male, however, all scores in the data set don't affect the
mode, necessarily. Take this data set. The mode is 22 because it occurs 3 times
and the rest of them occur once. However, if we take away the value 14, the mode
will still be 22. Now, let's say we add an extreme value like 1 million, the
mode will still be 22. So, we cannot say that all scores in the data set will
impact the mode, this one is also false, if we take a bunch of samples from a
population the mode is likely to change from sample to sample, let's illustrate
this idea with this applet, its really cool. Tthis is a histogram distribution,
this is called the bell shape curve and let's pick a random 5 sample that this
software will generate for us So just look at these top two. You see that the
mode is here, which is kind of at the left of this distribution. Let's do it
again. Now the mode's here at the right of the distribution. If we do it again,
the modes again, at the kind of far left of the distribution. Now here, there's
not even a mode. So you can see that if we take samples, the mode is somewhat
arbitrary and it won't necessarily be similar to other modes and it also won't
necessarily represent the population. Another thing about the mode is that it
changes as you change the bin size. So, if we make the bin size smaller, looks
like the mode is going to the left. Here it's at about 470. Here it looks like
it starts at about 450. And the mode changes as we change the bin size. If we
make the bin size really big, then the mode occurs in this interval, between 346
and 514 point 74. So the mode really depends on how you present the data.
Because this third point is false, we can't really use the mode to learn about
our population. And this is our goal in this course, inferential statistics. But
still, the mode is important to take into account when describing a data set.
And finally, this last one is false. While there's a procedure to find the mode,
where you look at all the data values, you see which one occurs the most, or you
look at the histogram and you see which bin has the highest frequency, we can't
describe the mode with an equation, and this is why we often use the mean, or
the average.